the movie is set in the year 2050 it's
been found that dark energy is
destabilizing the sun and it is quickly
dying threatening all life on Earth with
a new Ice Age however after some serious
research scientists have concluded that
a nuclear fission bomb with a mass
equivalent of Manhattan Island can
reignite the dying Sun The Icarus one a
prototype spacecraft with advanced heat
shielding and a sophisticated artificial
intelligence is tasked with the arduous
journey of transporting the payload to
the Sun an experienced crew fled by
Captain pinbacker is sent for the
mission but unfortunately it fails and
the spacecraft is Lost in Space seven
years have passed by and humanity is
making a second attempt to resuscitate
the sun with the Icarus too the crew
consists of the mission leader Captain
Canada and several other experienced
members like physicist Robert Kappa who
is overseeing the final calculations for
the bomb's payload deployment and
detonation mace the head engineer and
Corazon the botanist responsible for
maintain meaning the oxygen Garden that
provides both food and carbon to recycle
the atmosphere during the trip after 16
long months the ship finally nears the
sun however the solar noise known as The
Dead Zone begins to interfere with radio
communications to Earth a week earlier
than expected as a result the crew is
left with just 24 hours to collect all
of their individual thoughts and send
them to their loved ones back home
during kappa's turn he has difficulty
finding the right words and makes
several attempts at his message
unintentionally exhausting all of the
remaining time this enrages mace and a
fight breaks out between the two
fortunately the crew breaks their fight
and sends mace to spend some time in the
earth room which simulates the exact
atmosphere on Earth later when the crew
meets to discuss their latest progress
the spacecraft botanist Corazon notes
that the ship already has enough oxygen
stored up for the delivery and the
return trip as they get closer to the
Sun the ship's medical physician Dr
Cyril becomes fascinated with the view
from the ship's viewport he becomes
curious to experience the unfiltered
view of the sun however the AI warns him
that he can only tolerate 3.1 percent of
the actual light despite this Cyril
keeps exposing himself to the sun
causing his skin to peel away meanwhile
Captain Canada researches the video logs
of Captain pinbacker the commander of
Icarus one in an attempt to discover why
the original Mission failed he plays one
video where a pinbacker describes a
small meteor storm that did superficial
damage to the Icarus one as the ship
approaches Mercury communication
specialist Harvey picks up a signal from
The Icarus ones distressed Beacon
however he only hears faint signals
because it was Amplified by the iron in
Mercury's Mass he becomes sure that some
of those aboard Icarus 1 could still be
alive and discusses with his crew
whether the current Mission should be
altered in order to check on the Icarus
one's distress Beacon as expected mace
is not happy with the suggestion and he
tells everyone that it's a Dangerous
Mission however Dr Searle contradicts
that diverting to the Icarus 1 could
possibly add a second mom and having two
could be advantageous if something goes
wrong with the first one this results in
a heated discussion and Captain Canada
puts an end to it by handing the
decision to the ship's most informed
person in these matters their nuclear
physicist Robert Kappa however Kappa
also has a hard time making a decision
left with no choice he flips a coin
which finalizes them heading to rescue
Icarus one what no no you're not
two-faced you're scarecrow the crew is
forced to oblige and the ship's
Navigator Trey plots the course he
checks it three separate times and
becomes sure that he has been accurate
Trey then shifts The Icarus 2's course
to intercept The Icarus one however in
the many calculations Trey misses one
the need to readjust the heat shield
that protects the ship from the sun's
radiation sounds important how did he
miss that this error is discovered when
there is an emergency declared by the
computer after slight damage to the heat
shield unfortunately the true extent of
the damage can only be assessed and
repaired by leaving the ship and working
out in space Captain Canada and Kappa
volunteer for the dangerous and start
the necessary preparations as the two
exit the ship in Eva suits to begin
repairs the pilot Cassie reorients The
Icarus 2 in order to provide the two
spacewalking astronauts as much shade as
she can she does this despite knowing
that it will result in the loss of the
two Communications Towers needed to
return to Earth later in no time the
tips of the com Towers burn up as they
continue to revolve around the living
quarters in and out of the sunlight
consequently Cassian weddingly sets off
another chain of events when the still
revolving and burning remnants of the
communications Tower causes a beam of
sunlight to deflect towards the center
of the ship and onto the oxygen Garden
soon a fire breaks out that burns down
the garden and threatens to engulf the
entire ship Corazon quickly rushes to a
rapidly burning garden and requests
entry thinking that she can save it
however mace weighs up the situation and
realizes that the mission and the ship
will be lost unless drastic action is
taken so he orders the computer to
release all the stored oxygen in the
tanks to provide such an enormous boost
to the fire that it will literally blow
itself out he also realizes that this
will completely destroy the garden
during this event the artificial
intelligence begins to take automatic
control of the Icarus too it also tries
to return the heat shield back to cover
the living quarters despite the fact
that it is currently protecting captain
and Kappa who are still outside Cassie
realizes that this maneuver will result
in the death of the two spacewalkers and
she tries to countermand the order but
the AI refuses to budge with time
running out the AI and Cassie fight over
control for a few moments with the
latter eventually using an override
command that needs to be authorized by a
second crew member Cassie turns to mace
and seeks his authorization code but he
refuses he believes that the importance
of the mission Far outweighs the loss of
Canada and Kappa Cassie then pleads with
Harvey and fortunately he issues his
authorization enraged mace directly
calls Captain Canada and asks him to
support him in countermanding the orders
issued by Cassie and Harvey a decision
that will result in his own death and
that of Kappa as expected the dutiful
Captain Canada agrees with mace that the
mission is more important than his and
kappa's life the captain then tells the
AI to resume corrective shading and
proceed with the mission the AI obliges
and does the cover for the two
astronauts is diminished Canada orders
Kappa to go back to the safety of the
ship as he patches the last of the heat
shield damage by himself Kappa
reluctantly complies and shortly after
Canada fixes the remaining damage he is
exposed to the Sun and killed because of
the loss of their oxygen Garden the crew
is now forced to intercept Icarus one
Trey panics and starts blaming himself
for the incident hence the crew puts him
inside an isolation room so that he
doesn't commit the unthinkable in the
next scene the ship eventually reaches
Icarus one Cyril Kappa mace and Harvey
board the ship through an airlock and to
discover that there is enough food a
flourishing oxygen garden and a workable
payload aboard however there has been
extensive damage to the ship's computer
servers which will not allow the ship to
move the crew also sees a video log from
the late Icarus ones captain pinbacker
in the video pinbacker is sporting signs
of disfigurement and suggests that the
ship's crew chose to scrub the mission
believing that Humanity's impending
destruction was God's will that's what
happens when you send a religious guy to
do space science additionally All crew
members of Icarus 1 are found burned to
death in the viewing room which is a
result of the protective filter being
turned off as the group continues
investigating the airlock connecting the
two ships gets mysteriously destroyed
and both ships are pulled apart the crew
inside Icarus won panics and looks
around for ways to escape they
eventually find one Eva suit and Mason
Searle decide that Kappa should use it
as he is the only one able to deploy the
payload why was Mace cool with Kappa
dying earlier then however communication
specialist Harvey who is also the new
captain following Canada's Death Wants
the suit for himself this results in a
brief argument but Harvey is eventually
dismissed the crew then decides amongst
themselves that Cyril will stay back at
Icarus 1 to manually open the shafts
while Harvey and mace use the insulation
of the ship to cover themselves so that
they can hold on to Kappa as he is shot
towards the Icarus too unfortunately
during the attempt Kappa and mace make
it to the Icarus too but the former
loses his grip on Harvey as a result
Harvey drifts off into outer space and
is frozen his body can be seen breaking
apart when it collides with the ship and
burning up when his corpse leaves the
protection of the heat shield it's a
badass way to go meanwhile Cyril enters
Icarus one's viewing room to prepare for
his death and as soon as Icarus 2 leaves
the shielding from the Sun is gone and
Cyril is burned to death back at the
Icarus 2 Corazon calculates how much
oxygen they have and how much they need
to complete the mission after a bit of
research she concludes that there is
enough oxygen for four of the five of
them to live and deliver the payload
realizing that Trey is the biggest
liability the crew reluctantly decides
to finish him off however when mace goes
to carry out the ACT he finds Trey has
already committed the unthinkable The
Psychotic mace then viciously smears
some of the blood on kappa's hand
blaming him for Trey's death soon the
fight breaks out between the two but it
doesn't last long as they have trouble
breathing Kappa immediately heads to the
payload room and learns from the AI that
there is still not enough oxygen for all
of them to live until they deliver the
payload this puzzles Kappa has corazoned
did the math and there should be enough
oxygen for all four surviving crew
members surprisingly the AI tells him
that there are actually five people on
board the ship at the moment and the
fifth person is in the viewing room
stunned Kappa races to the viewing room
and discovers that pinbacker captain of
Icarus one is still alive he is terribly
burnt everywhere on his body and is
clearly psychotic it is also revealed
that he is the one who destroyed the
airlock connecting the two ships earlier
pinbacker slices the wound and cap his
chest with a stolen scalpel and chases
him through the ship Kappa makes it to
the Eva suit room and locks himself in
however pinbacker pulls the safety lever
and traps him in the room the lunatic
then removes The Icarus 2's computer
servers from their coolant causing the
entire ship to shut down here it is
revealed that he did the same on his own
ship and that is how his crew died
unbeknownst to all of this Corazon finds
a tiny seedling growing out of the burnt
soil in the burned out oxygen Garden
this gives her and the mission hope of
not just survival but even returning to
Earth excited she calls out for Kappa
and Cassie but ends up attracting the
attention of pinbacker who brutally
murders her elsewhere mace goes into the
cooling unit to fix the Icarus 2's
Mainframe by immersing himself in the
coolant he somehow manages to get the
power back on but in the process becomes
severely frostbitten on the other hand
pinbacker starts going after Cassie he
chases her throughout the ship prompting
her to hide in the nuclear payload
meanwhile trapped in the Eva suit room
Kappa talks to mace before he dies mace
in agony from the freezing coolant tells
Kappa not to worry because he's going to
wake up in New York City in about 70
years wait what this is oh sorry he
tells Kappa that he'll have to manually
decouple the nuclear payload from Icarus
and fly it directly into the sun he
eventually passes away while begging
Kappa to complete the mission later
Kappa punctures the inner door with a
welding torch and escapes from the room
by donning an Eva suit he then decouples
the payload and walks to the front hatch
of the ship as the payload and Icarus 2
drift apart Kappa uses the propulsion
unit of his Eva suit to fly to the
payload as soon as he lands the payloads
thrusters fire and burn up part of the
Icarus 2 causing the ship to explode
shortly after kappa goes into the
payload to manually pilot and ignite it
there he finds a distraught Cassie and
tries to help her up but just then the
psychotic pinbacker arrives at the scene
and ambushes Kappa he starts rambling
about God and is about to finish off
Kappa but fortunately Cassie comes to
the rescue the two then double up and
eventually Escape pinbacker's clutches
by this time the payload is neared the
sun's surface Kappa sees pinbacker on
the edge of the bomb but decides to
concentrate on the task at hand he
quickly ignites the payload and starts
the nuclear reaction in no time the sun
bursts into large flames and kappa's
stares into it as if he has found peace
he even touches the Flames before dying
back on Earth Robert kappa's sister and
her children are outside in a park
covered with snow as she watches the
last message sent to her by Kappa the
movie ends as the Sun finally comes out
after years and brightens the Frozen
Sydney Harbor indicating that the heroic
crew has succeeded in their mission
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching